[Music]
welcome to the inaugural 2018 air
biscuit
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're going
to be talking to one another about our
break we got a catch up right it's one
of those times catch up you know because
we we etch up set it up and knock it
down we haven't we haven't spoken a
whole lot we've already done quite a bit
of work we have just over the past few
days we haven't spoken that much about
what we did because we don't spend time
together over the holidays as a policy
yeah we of course we both go home to
North Carolina in order to see our
family and we each have the things that
we do which you know it will be part of
us will clue you in on that and the
things that we give each other updates
but one of the things we don't do is get
together or speak to each other or like
if we happen to run into each other it's
just that's gonna be just happenstance
yeah we're certainly no work happening
we're like how very strict about that
which did happen randomly which we will
talk about well the first thing is we
booked our flights to go home
independently and then we find out you
know weeks before we go home that we're
on the same flight well that's a little
bit of an over season that what happened
know what our books our books we said we
wanted to go home the same day
my flights were booked for us and then
the flight the person who booked the
flights was like well I'm gonna put them
on the same we independently chose the
same day to go home and we chose a
different day to come back incidentally
the same flight that guava juice was on
yeah we saw we're a very ggj call em gjj
you think in the end that's a--that's a
shortening of terminal no one ever says
like GJ because it sounds like you
calling somebody DJ but you have like a
speech impediment
GJ but we did see GJ got some got some
pictures with him no we didn't people
came up and got pictures with him
we watched yeah it was knock we watched
that we didn't talk about I did get a
picture with a very was that a very the
very tall basketball player was that
that tripper was that a different trip
no that was that was like one of the
last stops on the tour myth I was just
trying to give myself some sort of
validation like someone named up to us
and somebody also wanted to picture with
me nobody a picture with us
nobody well a picture with GJ and when
you're when you're in a group with so
many kids it's like oh that must be like
a school girls school like the high why
would I want pictures with those
chaperones when I can get a picture with
guava juice right I think is what
everyone in the terminal was thinking so
and then we got on the flight oh you
want to talk about the flight and we
didn't talk to each other because that
was once she cross once she went into
the sky that's when it began were we're
on our separate holiday begins I
wouldn't call it vacation I think I
think we went into that before we did it
like we anticipated that this is not
called vacation this is called a family
reconnaissance mission well I love my
family
I act and I can still say that on the
back side of being there yeah but I
actually got but I did not vacate I got
some you can be a little bit jealous
because I got some a long time that's
the way it worked out for me for a
couple of days I used the restroom by
myself I took showers alone long showers
in that long but I'll put that down as a
complaint actually I actually so one of
the things that happened is showering it
alone part is a you know we stay with my
sister-in-law and which incidentally I
mean point number one is I am sharing a
bathroom with teenage boys and that's
not something two of them well if you
count my son three of them three teenage
boys and then a nine year old you think
you know when you get to t man yes
how many sinks are in there there's two
sinks okay but it wasn't like one is
designated the teenage boy sink boy that
would have been convenient I should have
thought about that I should have written
that over the sink with a lipstick or
something
they have lipstick in there I'm sure I
could have found some or maybe I just
printed it out teenage boys use this
thing for whatever purpose you use sinks
for I
don't think it would be nice to start
designating who sync is who and someone
else's bathroom but just taking a shower
in a place that a teenage boy showers
it's just not something that I just not
something I'm interested in I mean I
have a different bathroom from my kids
for a reason because they disrespect the
bathroom you know what I'm saying it
smells weird in there all the time
they cannot hit the toilet to save their
life
eastream yeah what I mean I'm taller
than they are I'm further away from the
toilet than they are I still hit it
every time you got more experience I got
a lot more experience I mean if you make
them clean it up a few times
do they have to clean up their own piece
bladder no I do you did yeah
I mean well I do that here listen you're
not pee not cleaning up after me I
cleaned up the toilet I am like a
freakin bull yesterday every time I
I mean I rummaged under the sink and I
got out the sprayer and the brusher and
you know what come to think of it I
cleaned off the freaking rim of the
toilet just not 17 minutes ago I saw
that and that was after yesterday I
cleaned the whole toilet the stage
bathroom you in the state the state
bathroom somebody had a big old just
circle a piss a dollop of it had dried I
looked it so what that means is that
somebody did it you could clearly see
that it was there and then they let it
dry and that means other people saw I
don't know if you see it until it dries
leave it to me it come in there at the
benefit I'm wiping benefit of the doubt
that's not my job anymore did you do it
yes and I did it to where dads know
we're relating the toilets in our own
company literally something's wrong
yesterday I cleaned the toilet we didn't
end today you clean the same toilet did
you use the Lysol spray I'm in the brush
I didn't get that into it
what do you mean what you just you use
the you scrunched up toilet paper and
use your hand yes there's a brush with a
hand oh right sorry we don't listen you
got it
it wasn't a full commitment toilet
cleaning it was literally like I got a
pee I need to get to wardrobe to change
but there's this pee doll up there and I
don't and I feel like I should take care
of it so I did that quick it really
the quick rip ball up and white yeah and
then then wash oh yeah yeah cuz even
though I don't think I came in contact
with the pissed dollop I did I just feel
like it probably could have contaminated
me I thought about putting a sign but
you know signs in like a in like an
environment like this don't do any good
I mean we had there I'm like don't leave
dirty dishes in the sink and that hasn't
were there two years it's still there
though I mean the signs there but it
doesn't do any good you mean like office
signs corporate office yeah like we
can't are we getting that corporate it's
sad we had those for a year I mean I
literally I thought said we're going
through my head were if I put up a sign
and it said whenever you're done using
the toilet look down at what you've done
to it
yeah like don't just get up from the
toilet flush and assume it's a happy
ending you've got to turn around and
look at what you're leaving behind this
won't work and and I don't telling this
well it's not a pithy sign you got I got
a wordsmith it but it's like when you're
done turn around son what about they do
make you look at Cracker Barrel look at
what you did at Cracker Barrel they make
these kinds of signs and it's a little
humorous so it takes the edge off that
doesn't help when you take Oh what is it
if you sprinkle when you tinkle please
be neat and wipe the see yeah exactly
cracker barrels already already thought
of this man incidentally I went to
Cracker Barrel over the break Cracker
Barrel was recently not it's not a
sponsor but they were recently voted
there was a dude that went out and tried
all the fast-food restaurants the chain
restaurants okay not fast food but chain
restaurants and a dude like a journal
like a like a real restaurant person
okay critic this is second-hand
secondhand at this point but all I know
is that the second-hand second-hand
boiled down version this is not like a
tasty producer no is this like something
like a lid the the buzz of the story the
hook of the story is professional
restaurant critic reviews legitimately
reviews fast food that fast food chain
restaurants and Cracker Barrel was on
the list and like IHOP was on the
and Cracker Barrel was the top Oh
well cousin first of all that sounds
like fun there's also a new hipster
Cracker Barrel somebody look this
hipster barrel know something could the
people who make Cracker Barrel again
this is like third hand third hand you
don't know what you're talking so y'all
look that up the crackers are the people
that go and Google hipster Cracker
Barrel yeah because the people who make
Cracker Barrel are making a new
restaurant and it's like supposed to be
the hipster Cracker Barrel hollering -
holler where is that one word holler and
- and is it multiple locations really
like doing a test is it like holler -
holler ' - the letter in space -
ampersand ampersand that's the hipsters
like that holler and - and where is it
she's trying to figure it out okay but
see ya
allison alabama alabama is it birmingham
probably I don't know that Homewood
Alabama
Birmingham's got some history and okay
yeah yeah there's some greased mustaches
in Birmingham certainly so where were we
sharing a bathroom with teenage boys
yeah
not something that I would choose to do
but you're being you're being hosted man
you mean you can't no no I'm not
complaining Emma I I shared this is the
first I love my nephew I think I set
this up that night we got to we got to
stay in in my nephew who's two years old
did he pee all over the seasons and a
half he he does that in a diaper that's
better but given diapers of these guys
but our entire family shared his
bathroom which has one sink and then
like a Paddington the bear shower
curtain do you pee on that Paddington
Bear I don't know if there's a UH it
might be yogi the bear yeah I think I
was Smokey the Bear Yogi Bear in
Paddington Bear Paddington Paddington
Bear Paddington who happens to be a bear
so the thing that since we're
since we're talking about using toilets
but yeah we went there roll with it and
just to the right of the toilet is like
a basket with all of the stuff that you
bathe the two-year-old with right yeah
things that float and I bet and you got
to constantly distract them now it's
actually happening
I have immaculate aim when it comes to
doing number one yeah but even I know
and I am NOT above admitting this that I
along with everyone else does an
imperceptible spray even when you have
immaculate ain't micro talked about this
every once I'm special at one point then
the amount of the amount of kickback
that goes throughout the room right well
you want to flood you want to flush with
this with you won't put the lid down and
then flush just flushing alone and then
it's still not doing a lot of good so I
did just get out of the bathroom I
didn't flush and run what I didn't
hollering - what I didn't tell them and
and you know Lincoln and Lando were both
peeing into this toilet and Nehemiah my
two-year-old nephews bath toys is right
there beside the toilet and showered and
yeah and I I moved him but then I found
every day they'd be moved back so I
think what they would do is my
sister-in-law will go in there and she'd
put everything back or something do you
boys do a good job
yeah with with the pain no the toilet
seat in their bathroom at my home right
now I went in there to lift the seat and
it came off in my hand they've paid the
seat literally off of the toilet so I
don't think that's related I don't know
how they did us a structural issue so
every time that I go if I'm like doing
stuff in their neck of the woods and I
gotta use the bathroom I'll go in there
and I always lift the seat and I'll have
to like prop it up either against the
back or against the wall yeah I don't
know what they've been doing yeah I've
only peed in my in my kids bathroom once
in two years and I need to talk to
Christie I did it one time it was like
I'm never doing this again I will no I
will I will go out the window before I
come in here again our first stop was of
course we get off the plane and I'll let
you get back to your in-laws - I'm just
gonna pepper this in there for
chronology cuz I get off the plane
and I don't remember seeing you I think
you were gone yeah I left you on the
North Carolina side of things I do not
remember
oh no we walked out to the rental to the
rental area to like take the shuttle to
our cars and we were two different
rental cars so you get in a shuttle bus
and take off do you ever get mature get
your rental car
well could you use some company that I
used to spank company and it turns out
they were like a subsidiary of the place
you went on the first shuttle and then
20 minutes later when no shuttle showed
up I realized I was supposed to get on
your shuttle or they use pay less I used
because it was called I used the Avis
and then yes yes a Payless bought Avis
bought pay less yes they don't treat you
as well and as I pulled up in the zone
you want to pay less after yeah they
didn't take fee me good when I pulled up
I saw you leaving and I was like are you
kidding me I could have been on this
shuttle a 30 minute Avis preferred man I
just rolled up and got right in my car
got in the van and then my wife and I
have a superpower and it's put me in a
vehicle or in any enclosed environment
where there's been cigarettes smoked at
any point half a cigarette quarter of a
cigarette and we will know it and so
think that's a superpower it is and we
got in there and my kids are like you
know bouncing off the walls ready to get
to where we were going and Chris is like
mmm and I'm like I get it after I'm like
yep we get back out and we like take
another 20 minutes to get another car
because we both instant get instant
headaches when you in it's like had
cloth seats oh and it was all and that
you really went for the cheap oh man we
are really complaining on this ear
biscuit I'm sorry guys like but this
kind of redeems it for us to just bear
with us and there's no redemptive
element to the story I'm telling
just tell it complaining about it
redeems it for us you have no benefit
unless unless it entertains you for some
reason what was I saying okay so the we
get in the car finally we get in a
different car yeah and our first
tradition is we go to cookout and we I
get that burger and that peanut butter
milkshake the best milk brand you go
straight to cookout from the airport yes
because we have to drive all the way to
Kinston North Carolina I don't have
Chris you have to go here's his house
right and so I can't do that now that I
neither necessarily would just go to a
fast-food restaurant but we we meet a
family at home yeah and this time it was
we went straight to my brother's house
and they had Bojangles for us cuz it's
your mom's birthday right yeah on the
22nd it was my mom's birthday right so I
have to tell you this
we didn't you were they are celebrating
it yeah we didn't do anything because we
got there kind of late so it wasn't like
super special occasion you know also
she's like 71 now it's not as big as 70
who's countin maybe a 72 I'm not even
counting see I don't even know
is she counting I think she quit
counting ok well then it's fine got that
peanut butter shake got back on the road
I did notice once I got to my in-laws
that we're all we're all sharing and
Chrissy's sister and her husband and my
nephew they're all they are too and
we're all sharing a bathroom with one
toilet one sink in that place for two
nights and that's like a circus and I
noticed that I took my toiletries I'm
getting back to the toilet now
I took my toiletries and when I was done
using them I would I would put them in
the closet and hide them so like no one
has a chance at using my toiletries no
one has a chance of mikta rating you
know and then it's gonna settle on my
toilet you hit them I yeah just I mean
out of respect - there's so many
toiletries flying around what I
definitely don't want to leave yet I
wanna push mine out of the way they
brushed her toe without it now I
completely contains sealed my toiletries
I would bring them with me I would use
them and that would reseal them but I
didn't hide them I noticed that Kristy I
noticed that her toiletry bag in an
effort to be respectful to everyone
else's space she would take her toiletry
bag and she would put it in the corner
of the bathroom which happened to be
just to the side and behind the toilet
what did you talk with her buddy and I
moved it yeah and again I went in there
next day and it was moved back and I
forgot to tell her maybe she's listening
Christie don't do that and I also tell
her sister Brittany Brittany don't put
Nehemiah's bath toys around the toilet
wouldn't we're in town
cuz this stuff's getting sprayed yeah
did she and what did she put him she
kept putting it back there I didn't tell
her yeah I kept forgetting to tell her
it's you know it's not my place to just
go off on a rant that's this place right
you do that on a puck right okay well
we're gonna keep talking about our trips
back to North Carolina what we're gonna
move on from no more toilet can we go
out off the toilet no more toilets but
first we're gonna turn around and look
at what we've done let's let's look at
what we've done on the toilets and say
okay everything's cleaned up we're not
going back to it is this a metaphor yeah
I'm putting into practice what I said I
want people to do here at the office
okay look back at it like that rap song
that's the moral of the story look back
at it all right I'm gonna hand you
something like that I want you to hold
up he's getting warm in here too
can you can you flick that down to just
turn the heat off put it man it's like
it's feast or famine in this room you
know what yeah another thing we're
complaining about
but seriously in this room yeah what is
it the the barometer in the thermometer
that tells it I don't know I just made
that up the thing that the range of that
thermometer thermostat is is not good
okay but you know what is good the
cooler mythicality
commemorative culture we've got the tour
mythicality poster in the tour
mythicality t-shirt very similar the
poster is made of paper and the shirt is
made of cotton but the stuff on them is
similar but we also have the dates you
want to commemorate our tour or this
shirt just have a shirt you don't have
to commemorate anything even though
that's what it does go to a mythical dot
store and get this we're gonna we're
gonna hook you up with some with some
stuff that you need to check out we're
always adding stuff to that store now
you talked about your trip to cook out
and I thought about cook out and as I
was saying earlier I had a little free
time I'll tell you how the free time
came about so we stay in the same place
the entire trip because all of my family
is you know doesn't love you there
within a 10 to 15 mile radius of this
central location in Fuquay Varina North
Carolina so I don't have to travel all
over North Carolina we want like a home
base essentially but my kids but
basically what ended up happening this
time is my boys ended up going to my
brother's house
so they got cousins galore right we got
week and they got cousins that are boys
there are their contemporaries yeah and
they just love playing with them and
then what Shepard loves playing with his
his is my niece Adeline they're about
the same age and they're totally into
the same stuff and they just want to
play all the time Adeline is like I
wants to be outside constantly and
Shephard absolutely loves this that's a
great so they're like two peas in a pod
they're spending all this time together
and then my sister-in-law she'll like
text me and be like hey if the boys want
to stay here again tonight they can and
I'm like yes they do tell me you don't
even ask them cuz they like and they do
and they wanted to stay and then Jessie
was like well I've got these friends
that I need to see so I started seeing
my family begin to disperse and what
about your friends I wasn't going to say
anything I was like well I'm not gonna
make any plans because eventually you'll
all be gone and I'll just be left alone
oh and I don't even think they realized
that they left me and also my my
sister-in-law and brother-in-law and
their kids they had to go to some event
in Western North Carolina so I just
found myself alone in a home I was like
it's like home alone five this hasn't
happened in years I'm alone in a home
there's two dogs that's fine they don't
talk much no and so I was like well what
am I gonna do with this I had basically
two days of this what yeah so
therapeutic
hey well the first thing I did is I I
played through a game on my new iPad I
don't know I put quotes around iPad did
a generic know it's a real iPad I'm
getting like tears of jealousy my burnt
I as well enough I might here my life
got me for Christmas and
iPad and iPad pro because I've been
talking about how I kind of want to make
a transition to using an iPad more than
just using a laptop one of the reasons
being the Apple pencil and doing stuff
in interacting even though Apple had a
pencil you've been freaking right on an
iPad like you're writing in a piece of
paper and it looks exactly like your
handwriting it's phenomenal and
fascinating because I like to ask for
six months I got a pencil and then Rhett
does not use his oh no no I'm gonna use
it okay I've been using it now because I
do a lot of it called pencil it's called
the Apple pencil how'd you miss this I
don't I don't like to be distracted by
stuff okay so you can it's been out for
a while this is not a new thing this is
like two old farts talking about
something from like three years ago okay
keep going but I it basically what I
wanted to do is I don't know I'm
defending the purchase of an iPad it's a
perfectly normal thing yes you have to
sharpen it maybe that's why I quit
working I mean that would be pretty cool
if you had to sharpen it but look about
hipster Cracker Barrel it's been it's
been scientifically proven that writing
things down as opposed to typing things
causes you to remember them better and
so if you take notes just with your type
II types
it doesn't lodge in your brain in the
same way that it does if you there's a
physical connection in the way that
handwriting brings about a physical
connection with information so I like to
take notes and like write thoughts and
stuff but I've got these well I use
canvas not mspaint and I've got a lot of
like little like moleskin books
yes tough and I'm kind of in this and
that but you know I can't access them by
the date and stuff unless I flip through
them sure but so the cool thing about
this is I can like journal what a what a
drudgery that is I can like journal or
take notes but then I can also be like I
don't feel like riding my arm my hands
tired I'm gonna type and it puts it all
into the right place in the cloud - so
if California burns away exactly
mudslides into the ocean right then you
still got your your you
necessity but then I was like you know
something I don't do I don't play any
games because we fill all our time with
working or with you know hanging out
with family and so I was like I'm going
to play a game on the iPad so you were
like okay pencil recommend a game you
know that's not how it works it doesn't
talk you know it's only $200 it's not
like a $2,000 pencil that listens to you
so is what I'm getting so I said I'm
gonna go on and I and I got this game
call it's an old game it's like a 2012
game called limbo that is this like
award-winning beautiful side-scroller
puzzles well yeah but it's just amazing
you guys ever heard of this game it's
this great it's an incredible game
that's like you're this little boy
character but it's all black and white
and it's like dark and you get killed in
all these different ways like I died
like a thousand times in this game but
you you don't really know when you've
like gotten to a new spot in the game
mm-hmm because it's just this world that
just continues and it's relatively short
so you can play through it in a couple
of days a couple so the so you were
alone and you downloaded this game this
was the choice mm-hmm this is what you
were gonna do with your day yeah I was
like I've never done that I hear there
are people who just sit down and play
video games for like hours what is it
like to be that kind of person I'm gonna
find out what did like if it were me
I'll be like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
make my drink and it's gonna be special
and I'ma sit in a special chair and I'm
aware of my special PJ's this are you
this is how you talk to yourself in my
mind yeah I would get everything right
like did you to play a freaking game if
I mean if if if I was gonna be that
alone for the first time in years to do
something that only normal people do and
not I mean in the way you're thinking
about it like playing a game for fun
special PJ's no I just sat down on a
couch and played it all day uh drink a
special drink I drink several drinks but
they weren't special they were just for
sustenance so I could keep playing that
game okay
but I beat the game I only consulted the
internet twice how long did it take
I mean did you do it in that I didn't I
didn't finish in those two days I
finished over the break eventually I
after I started it I kept going back to
it I don't know ten hours it's probably
a lot probably total I don't know but I
kind of concluded that I don't know if I
want to do that again I think the more
the story is yeah I got through beating
the game and I was like you know and
this is I'm gonna be very vulnerable
here I almost cried yeah the game was so
beautiful and you kept you kept being
murdered on it like a moment-by-moment
basis and it was a beautiful thing and
what at the end the way that it's just a
beautiful game and in the way that the
game ends and you go and you saw the
last puzzle in goes into slow-mo and
then you get up and there's this spoiler
alert it's from 2012 who cares there's a
girl and she like looks up and it's I
don't and I was just like is it
animation yeah like this part is not
like no it looks like it's just more of
the game okay but it's a game so
beautiful that I found myself like
almost crying and then I was like I
don't know how I want to do that again I
mean it was pretty satisfying but I kind
of feel like I wasted time I probably
should have been coming up with things I
think that's important to not come up
with things that I mean we talked about
that yeah I was true that was one of the
things cuz I because we'd worked so hard
in 2013 that I just don't want to do the
thing that I always do yeah which is
just work and I've been doing this that
you know the Enneagram stuff the
personality test stuff in like which I
want to talk about on a pot on the
podcast at some point like but I don't I
don't want to give it short shrift
whatever shrift is yeah right now I just
like Bitcoin I think but they don't even
believe in it but then it's gonna be
pretty amazing there's like a
personality testing that we've gotten
into Ania Graham that's really awesome
we'll talk about it later but one of the
things I we he means him and his his his
his game avatar yeah itself and one of
the things that's true about my
personality type and then this is also
true about your personality type you
know it's different is this feeling of
if you're not working you're like
worthless yeah you know so like long
periods of inactivity or just
vacationing or just hanging out you feel
like you have to give yourself home
ress is very difficult to just stop and
play a game very difficult for me to do
but but but for a create for creative
people I got a feel thank man you got to
fill the tank with with something that
is aimless and and I'm gonna I want to
hear from you in a sec I just want to
get to this point because the whole
point of the story was to tell you about
how I'm already very jealous I went to
please keep going to cook out oh and
miss you did get a special drink yeah no
I didn't get it a special mark I didn't
get a milkshake guys say man it's good
but it's just not what you built it up
too much I mean I went there I got the
burger cheddar saw but did you replace
the cheddar with sliced cheese okay a
burger doesn't have to have all these
very specific choices in order to be a
good burger I got the Carolina style
burger with cheese added never had that
okay but it's a I mean it's all the
things that I like it's it's a good
burger people have told me well you got
to go back and get the chicken sandwich
it was really good too and I'm like why
can't I I'm here such little precious
little time that I went back and got on
New Year's Eve it was freezing you
remember that I do remember that and I
was here actually I don't remember
turning my brother-in-law back all right
I was still there was like 72 here I was
freezing and we were watching Steve
Harvey and I turned to my brother-in-law
and I said I think we had we had planned
this out earlier but but I said it in
action that moment sight we can't forget
to go get that milkshake we were talking
about to ring in the New Year and we got
in oh shoot
I just remember something that I vowed I
would not forget to tell you oh and I
just remembered it well just to finish
that thought we got in the car to go to
cookout but it was no mere car it was
the truck truck did you were you in the
JB my brother-in-law's friend who came
over with his wife to hang out while we
just watched the ball drop and ring in
the new year at their home so the case
would go to sleep at their leisure
drives up in his truck and JB had told
me earlier that day or the day before
New Year's Eve you just traveling around
going to cook out like as the balls
dropping no no no like it like 9:45 or
so still pretty late yeah yeah I was
like and it was opened cuz I was yeah it
was open
I got a peanut butter milkshake but the
way we got there was in the truck that
this friend of my brother-in-law it's
his truck
am I being clear about this it's very
strange you seem like you're about to
say something significant about the
truck but you just keep saying that it's
a truck well just let me get to it is
there something special about the truck
it's a big Ford truck you know how you
can get away with driving those huge
trucks in North Carolina but you can't
do that out here in Los Angeles then you
can't fit him anywhere out here can't
Park it anyway you can't drive it in
anything you can drive it through stuff
but people would be offended and you
it'd be insurance yeah JB said this
guy's trucks got everything it's got
massage chairs
what massage chairs in his truck his
truck that seems a little not one
driving driving well massage but two
massage chairs driving under the
influence of massage and JB JB told me
that and the moment he did I was like I
must ride in this truck to get a
milkshake yeah so he cut in so when I
found out that he was coming over I was
like yes and the moment this dude walked
in I just like you know how I get
sometimes I just clamped onto him yeah
I'm glad I wasn't just like I was like
good to meet you tell me about this
truck did he seem relaxed I don't
believe he seems super relaxed did he
seem I mean I would think somebody
that's got massage chairs in their car
just looked like a monk he was the
coolest guy I've ever walks in like a
slinky yeah you know just barely there's
slides in the door like a bowl of jell-o
he he was not that limber he was not
that what's the word jiggly he wasn't
jello II boy he probably used it once or
twice and he takes he's taking it for
granted now he's not me yeah when was
last time he massaged himself in his
truck
I asked him did he massage himself on
the way over there he said no yeah it's
like you and I see you you were like I
wouldn't want to be there but you do the
exact same thing you're doing it to me
now but I do it more subtly in person
I'll slide the questions like hey man
good to meet you tell me about your
truck because I heard something about it
that cannot be true
it's got massage chairs and he's like
yeah two of them so he was proud of it
and it's I mean to be clear the driver's
seat and the passenger seat there's
there's also two more seats behind it
because it's one of those four-door big
trucks you can he's got the big screen
in the middle and of course I was
already planning on getting a cookout
shake on New Year's Eve and then I'm
like oh the deal is sealed now we are
not gonna forget about this we get in
that car and like first of all we walk
out the front door trucks already
running I'm like like man we've been in
your house for two hours you let you
truck her on it no it's like remotely
that man I hit a button I'm like okay I
I knew that kid happened yeah but I
still don't believe your massage chair
and I get in there and he's like and he
turns on the massage we hit the road
jack are we just talking vibrate no are
we talking like kneading I'm talking
like kneading like kneading with K yeah
kneading with the K
shiatsu oh no she got sue your shiatsu
and me cuz I was like if we're talking
vibration like I've tried to read a book
while being in a vibrating massage chair
before and you cannot do it I can't
focus you can't read signs if you're
driving with a vibrating chair this
doesn't seem safe but kneading is fun
and he's like in and he was like just
wait and so then he like he turns it on
and it's and there's three levels and he
put it on level three for me he went
straight to three yeah he didn't want to
hold back him and break you short drive
to to a few quake yeah and it felt good
hmm I mean it's not like a person giving
you a massage of course but for it for a
chair in a truck that was going to get a
milkshake it's pretty great is it the
best massage you've ever had in a truck
going to get emotion yes absolutely and
it was the biggest moment of my life
that I can't believe I forgot to tell
you are you
gonna get these installed in your car
was it the kind of thing you only enjoy
there because what I do when I
experience um that I really like as I
find a way to get it in my own life you
can't I mean I would have to get one of
those big freakin trucks they they don't
I don't think they put those in in like
a just a normal vehicle you could
somebody somebody in an alley it's funny
because when Jamie first told me oh yeah
we just came back from the ball game
with so-and-so and he he's got massage
chairs in his truck and I'm like what
and I'm going through all that and he's
like all right I can't run what I was
going to say I'm so excited about the
freaking massage chair that I lost my
train of thought
it happens give me a second I'll give
you a few seconds I mean it literally
just sent my brain into just like I'm
done
like that's how great this massage chair
I want to talk about anything else he
said
it yeah it's so really it's great when
you when you just when you need to relax
or if you spent the day at the fair
that's what JB said that he said to him
and then when he comes over to the house
I'm like so you got massage chairs in
your truck and I'm like grilling about
he's like yeah it's great for when you
need you know you just need a little
massage when you spent the day at the
fair
I mean the State Fair is only around for
a few days he doesn't like a week he
just goes to it I don't know that was
his thing he's like if you spent all day
at the fair you want to drive home and
get a yeah Messire can be tough man I
mentioned like a full day of work but
and then it cook out he ordered a
pineapple banana milkshake and I gave
him a really hard time about that yeah
you should have he I mean I would never
let him sip it i grilled him so hard
about his massage chair and then about
that milkshake that I'm sure he hates me
I know this guy he's like your
brother-in-law is the weirdest human
deserves every bit of it for that
milkshake choice now what I will say I
couldn't get a milkshake because I try
to stay away from the milk products but
I did get chicken nuggets and corn dogs
asides because yes that is something you
can do at this restaurant believe it or
not and I gotta say I was underwhelmed
with both the Nuggets and the court the
where'd you eat it alone in my car in
the parking lot did they not being
massage that's that at all I mean I was
like I want a fresh I want this stuff
fresh man I didn't want to take it back
to the house was your iPad there oh yeah
you better believe it I was stopping
every once in a while to play a little
of that game and die and then I'd take a
bite of a corndog
it wasn't bad but it was not as good as
Steak and Shake and it was not as good
as five guys yeah I'm not gonna say it's
better than Steak and Shake but in five
guys is much better than I thought it
was but I don't want to say any more
about it than that
okay well maybe I just need to get
another one next time I also had another
meal where I was alone in a parking lot
I went I typically go to Smithfield's
barbecue chicken and barbeque yeah they
call it SC MB now it looks like a bank
sign yeah they change it up that was
dumb so stupid
yeah Smithfield's if you're listening
the SS Endon Golden Corral
not a good move closed how on earth does
a Golden Corral in Fuquay Varina close
like what what is the world coming to
didn't have enough in us all you can eat
buffet in Fuquay Varina
goes out of business there's only one
explanation they ran out of food that's
it there's no there's no other logical
explanation there is not well no the
other one is they opened a bigger one if
you blocks away there's another one
somewhere there's got to be another one
yeah definitely that's what happened but
I gotta say that the better sandwich in
my opinion was the was the barbecue
sandwich with slaw the bun is so soft
and I got a half pint of Brunswick stew
on the side and it was so good and
where'd you eat that in the parking lot
of Smithfield's along again yeah which
is very close to the cookout parking lot
I spent a lot of time alone I didn't
mind I enjoyed it oh yeah oh yeah I mean
we dedicated a whole chapter of the book
to it yeah but I did have some family
time and one of the one of them it
actually sent you a picture of this hold
on no no no is this the Gaga yeah you
Instagram this no I didn't oh I sent it
to our to our group text that that's
where you saw oh that's what it was okay
yeah I thought about putting it on
Instagram but then I thought yeah you do
something like that and people just
start complain
you know should you should you not talk
about it here no I'll talk about it here
oh yeah it cuz I cuz you know this is
inner circle stuff my grandmother-in-law
gaga great picture by whom you've read
about in the book of mythicality cuz
you've read the book of mythicality and
you know the important role that she
played in my relationship with my wife
in the early stages when she was 75
years old now she's 92 or 3 Wow and she
was this health nut for ever you know
you you know like she was the one that
had like all the crazy like supplements
and she did like the Hallelujah Acres
diet thing you know she debunked that
milk was good for you
oh she remember you came you brought
that to me and she shot her she would a
day told me about how bad milk was and
then and the way she talks about
traditional medicine is I think she
calls it cut burn and poke or something
like that like she just does arjen's she
doesn't like traditional medicine and
she walked all the time and she was
completely self-sufficient even after
her husband died but she had smut not
that you need a husband to be
self-sufficient no no I'm saying a lot
of times when you're old and yeah you
know your spouse dies things go downhill
right but that didn't happen with her so
she was a smoker can you turn the heat
back oh my gosh come on are you kidding
I'm getting cold jacks just joking jack
you want me to literally get up in the
middle of podcast nude jumping jacks you
think that will be more distracting than
what I just did before you made me drag
it out into this I know there is now
less stress less destructive then do it
than this so she used to smoke which is
very excusable as someone who is her age
in North Carolina her husband worked in
tobacco so she naturally smoked a little
bit as a as a young lady yeah and then
we found out that she occasionally
smoked all throughout this whole health
nut craze really but just like very
occasionally she'd sneak a cig snicker
ative ly but something has just clicked
in the past two years where I think she
hit 90 and she's just like who cares now
if I want to smoke I'm gonna smoke and
she's smoking a lot and she cut she came
over to the
to the house and she's hanging out and
then she's like I gotta smoke a
cigarette and we're like ok gaga but you
can't do it inside so we put her on the
Sun porch the onion the unheated Sun
porch ha we didn't put her there she
went there and so she's got the in the
picture you know she's got the blanket
this is my perspective when I saw the
picture there was a caption but first I
read the picture and it was like it's so
funny it was cute
very old Gaga totally bundled up like
layers upon layers upon layers and she's
got two hands in the air with two
fingers up any each one looking into the
camera
smiling blissfully and in each perched
between each of her two fingers on both
hands is a cigarette yeah she's double
fisted she's double fisting cigarettes
smiling into the camera and then I'm
like there's like a weird sheen on the
front of the photo of reflection if you
will and Ivy and I and I explained it in
the text yeah I said notice the
reflection that's because I took this
from inside the house she's on the porch
you pushed her you pushed her out no you
said the frigid cold he knew she
couldn't smoke in the house although we
did here whose cigarette we did here
I'll tell you how she got to cigarettes
but we heard a story Shh she she ran a
killer right there she went over to
somebody's house
my mother-in-law told me this story her
daughter they went over to a friend's
house and then Gaga was like I want to
smoke a cigarette and my mother-in-law
was like buh kagyu mom you can't you
can't smoke in somebody's house and she
was like what kind of person doesn't let
you smoke inside their house like she's
just you know that's just that's who
she's become and she's totally embracing
it so the reason she had two cigarettes
is because she goes out there by herself
I'm a brother-in-law who does not smoke
I mean he's probably had a cigarette
before but he does not smoke cause like
I feel like I should just go out there
smoke one with her out of solidarity you
know she's out you got a 92 year old
woman out there in the cold Sun porch
smoking a cigarette I'm gonna go out
there and so he lights one up and he
takes a couple of puffs he's like I just
can't do it I can't finish this so he
gives it she's like well don't put it
out give it
me and so that's why she had two
cigarettes and that's why there was a
scene because you were in the warmth
yeah taking a photo of her yeah zoo
animal no she she knows that's funny
she you know she absolutely knows that
it's funny that's half the reason that
she does it but also she's like I don't
really care if I keep living I just want
to have a good time I made it to 90 it's
uh I mean one of them on a sadder note
this is one of the reasons we make sure
to go back home is you want to see
everybody but you definitely want to see
the older relatives and you know I've
been blessed with a lot of my
grandparents still living three of them
yeah three out of four my grandparents
are still alive
Nana and Papa my dad's parents and nanny
my mom's mom now her husband Clyde died
when I was a junior in college um but
you know they're they're getting up
their nanny had a stroke she wasn't she
went really went through it earlier this
year and it was difficult to not be
there so it's like you you want to go
home because well you don't want to you
know you say it you say it to Chrissy
and I talk about it it's like well this
may be the this may be the last
Christmas you know I mean Nana and pop
are doing better much much better than
nanny is but you know that's kind of
like the tough aspect it's like okay
you're gonna you know you and Jessi are
gonna see gaga and how many more times
you're gonna get to see her like we go
to nanny's in the tradition as we go
there on Christmas Eve and you know
she's not she's not able to really leave
the house and you know at the point
where we're gonna exchange presents it's
like this year it was at that moment she
just burst into tears and it was so sad
but good and then she said and she
doesn't talk a lot after the stroke like
because she has a hard time putting
words together and it was this like sad
speech where she just like it just came
out and she was like I just couldn't get
you any gifts this year and it was like
this
this moment and we you know it's of
course we don't care about the gifts
then but as sad as that was you know
being able to respond to it and talk to
her about it and be there and to have a
have quality time with her and and just
reassure everybody that of course that's
not what this is about
it's not about presence was it you know
it turned a really sad moment into
something which you know I think was
very meaningful to us but I mean it's
that at this point in our lives that's
the that's a big part of the holidays is
okay who's who's still here that's not
gonna be here that much longer and you
know you start you know you so you start
to think about mortality and you start
to think about you know what can happen
to any of us
you know when it when the holidays of
that time of year when you think about
last year things are like this or year
before things were like that or but it's
also the time when you contribute to
your mortality by going in eating
barbecue fried chicken and biscuits yeah
yeah I mean if I had to eat if I had to
eat the way that now I know it's not
everybody in North Carolina eats like
this of course but more people in North
Carolina need to eat that way than they
do here and you know shout-out to
Brett's Instagram account read em see
it's one thing to promote your Instagram
it's another thing to do it in that way
in the third person yes I know you know
like that is tasteful those of you who
follow me on Instagram know that I did a
story haven't done a lot sense but I did
a story on New Year's Day maybe today
you know New Year's Eve I don't know
what it was but I was looking for a
healthy meal and I found one at this
place that was this weird smoothie place
that had like three step process where
you had to get a shot of aloe and then
he had to do a tea and then they gave
you the smoothie and I was like do I
have to go through these three steps and
it just hit me that maybe this was not
the simplest approach to setting up a
shop like this and Fuquay but whatever I
did it's great it was great uh yeah this
movie was good but
yeah it's just the way that we ate was
so hard on the body my GI has not
recovered but almost sharded a few
minutes ago really and I was telling you
it was I I don't know you know what
thanks I'm not going back to that I'm
just saying yeah you just die I think
it's because my everything is not just
everything's not in alignment
just leave it it I almost sharted it
we'll leave it there but let's talk
about when we get Bhumi actually did
meet because we had not planned on long
as your boss passed yeah we have no
intention of seeing each other we see
each other quite enough in fact we went
and did a little skiing together as
families after you got back right now
but but going from house to house for me
and Christy it's like you go north a few
Quay for anything and then when you
coming back it's like well I know
there's a target here and it's like well
we'll never know when we're gonna get
back to this target I got to buy a
blanket cuz make the bed warmer or I got
to get another pillow anything to make
yourself more comfortable or i'ma buy my
own groceries she was at Ulta which is
next to the target yeah we make up yeah
we were going to the target but then she
was like oh there's an Ulta well and my
wife was going into the Ulta as well and
that's when we saw Christy and I was
like there's Christy and then I saw you
and the kids and so in the car and that
was when I was doing my annual trip
where I take everybody I take the whole
family you know the my brother and his
family jesse sister and her family and
my parents take them all to see Star
Wars it's the tradition so far okay
we went to always wait to the last
minute to buy tickets and us like I'm
buying like 15 tickets it's like buy
that many tickets together it's kind of
a difficult thing to get you need to got
to do reserve seating so you can all be
together yeah and this is like you know
Star Wars are still peaking at that time
so the only place that we could find
enough seats together and we couldn't
even find 15 seats together was 7 & 8 we
had to separate the two different pods
on the back row which is better than the
front row was at that place in Holly
Springs next to where we met each other
that where's the food
I mean theater yeah that was the only
place that we could see it which is not
ideal for a number of reasons first of
all that place I had a horrible
experience there last year
and it's I don't I feel like this whole
podcast is just for people and fuqua
like why don't we just rename ear
biscuits like crap we want to complain
about related to fuqua well this is
Holly Springs so a little different all
right
but I don't I'm not a big fan of the
dine-in movie situation unless it's a
movie that I'm don't really care about
that much but like Star Wars is although
I'm not as big of a fan of it as you are
it's you know it's it's more of an
experience and yeah you got the
complication of people ordering food and
waiter there's waiters to come to the
freaking seats and of course they've got
a pass in front of me now you're on the
back row and the way that they've got
the the C tiered they've got the seating
tiered so you know like Beverly Hilton
but here's the problem we get in there
and they've got this glass what they did
my theory is they built the theater and
then somebody came in and said these
walls are not high enough and so they
had to build the walls higher for safety
reasons and now there's like a foot of
glass you're watching the movie through
glass and if you're if you're six foot
seven you're not but if you're four foot
six like Shepherd or whatever it is and
sit next to me he's looking his name is
Shepherd he's looking through the glass
to select the third the bottom I put my
head down where his was in the bottom
third of the screen is covered in glass
glass is dirty now you know how Gaga
felt putting her out there and she
wasn't watching Star Wars just watch you
guys being warm she's a happiest person
on the planet double-fisting cigarettes
nothing wrong with her Shepard complain
no cuz he's a kid but I did ask the
waiter was like can I get you any food I
said no but you could clean that glass
off Sasi I didn't say it quite like that
but he came back and he cleaned the
glass off but he cleaned one side of it
and the other side had smudges - but
Shepard you know I didn't care but then
the thing is that they it doesn't matter
who you are you can order you
can order food and Shepherd and a ladder
down there ordering popcorn just
pressing the button in there got the
waiter coming up I've got two nine year
olds just at will ordering food there's
all kinds of problems with this this
situation yeah well then I don't want to
know your opinion on the movie because
you know have to filter it I'm the glass
of all that I was the first of all I'm
not I'm not a Star Wars fan boy so I
don't have like the you know I'm not one
of those people it's gonna be like you
messed with something precious I know a
lot of people are upset about certain
things I thought it was a very solid
movie very entertaining I didn't enjoy
it as much as last year's movie but row
one the one with Harrison Ford in it
force awakens two years ago force
awakens yeah oh I didn't enjoy it as
much as the last two oh but I enjoyed it
a lot and I think they're all great well
if you want to know what I think you got
to follow me on Twitter because that did
tweet about that and I did respond to
some people well after I watched the
last little shout out what's your what's
your handle shout it out link Lamont
he's got a shout out shout out to links
Twitter link Lamont is exactly how you
said it except it was your information
um I went to my mom's house I want to
run this by you by way of your biscuit
closure I don't want to I'm gonna open a
can here towards me in the conversation
but bear with me a while I you know we
go to the in-laws house then we spend
most and then we go to my mom's house
and then we spent the majority of the
time after that you know getting
massages in trucks at my my Christie's
sister and her saucers and milkshakes
I'll be it awesome but can we combine
those two into an establishment yeah
yeah an RV you'd be moving it's mobile
mobile massage massage milkshake three
M's write that down I'll write that down
on my iPad the moment I step into my
mom's house I'm just struck with a scent
oh my god and it was strong and I've
been in my mom's house many times it's
not the house that I grew up in but her
and Lois it's their house I've been
there many years though
and never smell this smell and I'm like
should I say some again it was that
moment the moment it wasn't a cigarette
smell but at that moment you get in the
rental car and you're like sure should I
say should I send should I get it should
I send this car back and get another one
because I'm gonna have to live in this
car for the next weekend hell okay but
in this house you gotta give me know
that my mom's house doesn't smell like I
have to describe the smell because I
will the the once I know that the the
category of the smell I can tell you how
you should have reacted well I decided
it was so strong I decided I had to say
something to my mom and I was like mom
and this was in the first four minutes
of what kind of smell was it I said mom
do you smell that
well course she doesn't of course she
didn't and I'm like I it just smells
like mothballs
oh gosh ei shouldn't should I mention it
now I could have told you you could have
caught you should have texted me and
then could have broken our rule that
smells like mothballs you can't you
cannot question that I mean I'm like I
haven't smelled mothballs in a long time
but it's so pungent and it's like I feel
like it's I mean it's really strong like
he's about to knock me over and she's
like it is mothballs if you smells like
mothballs it is month well I have I have
moths eating my clothes in my closet I'm
like that really happens I thought that
was something that happened in the 50s
or something like I thought that was
eradicated like polio no we would just
know how it works it's plenty or
eradicated you can't go away you know
and it's coming back in some places it
is you cannot vaccine against moths the
bubonic plague is in Madagascar yeah
that's bad what I'm not going I really
feel for those people but I'm talking
about my mom right now she's like yeah
and and she was like so I put him in my
closet and then the the the vent blew on
them and then they all disappeared I
guess that's what happens when when air
blows on a moth mothballs is that they
disintegrate over time like you would
like one of those air freshener Bali
things she says but there's also a full
basket of them in
the guest bedroom in the closet and I'm
like oh that's my room and I go back
there and I open the door and Chris
she's already back there she's got this
like haunted look on her face cuz she
wasn't gonna say anything and I'm like
yes and I took the basket out and it
will knock your socks off and you're not
even a moth could you imagine if you
were a month gosh I would not eat
clothes if they smell like that yeah
right that's the ho yeah and she
graciously took them out and I'm just
like I cannot believe did the smell
leave with the balls we burned a candle
in there and she put those balls in her
closet in her bedroom and it still was
smell out at the place it never went
away but it went from like a 100% down
to a 20% you as a general rule I mean I
I guess my mom I can talk openly with my
mom yeah is your mom but if it was me I
wasn't a jerk about it I don't think I
get it I don't think you should ask
questions about smells unless you know
it's something that's dead it was so
strong like a new pile of Dookie that no
one has found yet look at that
but it's also but you can't it's you
can't live in a space that smells like
mothballs I'm sorry it's just it's -
there's got to be a no any a clean
solution remodel you can't live in us I
cannot I mean they can obviously they
don't have a problem they didn't think
anything twice about it but I just felt
like I could offer a service I know this
this sounds bad moth ball removal just
somebody who can come in and give you
their honest opinion about stuff no gosh
it's just so I got a job that's called
being linked but I think I would be good
at that job like I could go in to like
talk about massages I could go in I my
dream job would be to go into spas and
then review them and like consult
consult with spas yeah like this is big
this this is why I wanted more like the
intagram episode because you are the
category of Enneagram that is this is
what it's up your alley profile is a
reformer a reformer I thought I was in a
one a perfectionist that a reformer is a
one same thing I I just want to say it's
more specific than a perfectionist like
to be able to go in and like give an
honest opinion because I want to help
it's like you know other people are
gonna walk into your house and they're
gonna get hit with a wall of mothball
smell you know or like maybe you your
clothes don't match or mmm you know
maybe your pictures you haven't looked
at that picture in a while and it's in
it's been crooked for a couple of years
it's like someone just to come in with
fresh eyes or fresh nose or fresh senses
and just to like give give their opinion
I what what job is that I want to do
that I think it's just called pain in
the butt I know I sound I think that's
what it's called I think I think there
are people who the cumulative effect of
our conversation here I'm afraid that
the take away is because I'm
self-conscious about this is that you've
moved out to Los Angeles and you would
come too big for your britches you come
home and you tell your mama that it
stinks in your yeah even the cookout
burgers aren't good enough for you
anymore
I'm really self-conscious about that and
I'm afraid that that's what we've done
in this conversation no I think I'm like
talk about pre you know on the seat or
well that's clean about everything just
being a dad man that's just getting old
when you when you get to a certain stage
I just really care and you I really care
I mean it's not just about my homey it's
not caring I think it all it but it
could be interpreted as this like all
know what makes me comfortable
and well yeah and the world needs to
bend to me well I will say don't that I
told my wife because I because I do
think this is a component of this
because if you make yourself if you
expect you're in if you set yourself up
so that your environment has to be made
perfect in order for you to be happy you
will always be unhappy but if you set
yourself out to be someone who can be
malleable and flexible in any
environment and instead of saying I want
that picture to be straight and say I'm
gonna be okay with that picture not be
straight and I and I don't do that I for
the record I did not straighten any
pictures no but I'm saying but this is a
principle for everybody not just
somebody who has more pain
in an average but that what I told
Jessie when we got there knowing I was
gonna be sharing a bathroom with him any
kid I was marginal this wasn't
marginally affected because I still
complained about it I was like I'm gonna
not let this get me this year and I'm
gonna be like this is and this is an
opportunity for growth sharing a
bathroom with teenage boys as an
opportunity for growth it's also an
opportunity for entertainment when I can
go on a podcast and talk about yeah and
I think that that is my main reason I
think we're talking about is it's funny
for us to be but I do think that I took
a different approach to saying like you
know what I'm gonna do the things I want
to do like I'm going to clean the seat
I'm going to take my toiletries in and
out whatever so that I can enjoy this as
much as I can but I'm not gonna just sit
here and wish I was a hotel I'm not
gonna do that
because being here is being with family
and putting myself through this is
ultimately a good thing but it is a
little bit of a spoiled thing I you know
I share a bathroom with my wife is it
you know even just moving from sharing a
bathroom with dudes when I was a
roommate to you know Tim and Greg to
sharing a roommate with Jesse sharing a
bathroom with Jesse like it's there's a
totally different world I mean all of a
sudden there's somebody who's invested
in the cleanliness of this bathroom and
the smells being good and the you know
all these things and it's just like oh
this is great
that I can that I and you become spoiled
when you've had 17 years of that of
being using a bathroom in a place where
somebody cares about the environment and
then you go to a place where it's just
boys and I was a teenage boy at one
point yeah yeah yeah it's just a dirt
you know lesson approach let's let's
twist this into being about how great
our wives are and how it made us you
know you saw where I was gonna meet us
really they made our lives amazing yeah
they're not listening that's the sad
fart yeah yeah I just said fart sad part
all right guys that's it thanks for
enduring our complaints and from
believing the best about a student or
whatever opinions you've gathered I'm
sure you can let us know hashtag ear
biscuits don't know your opinions about
us
hello your opinions about our work
alright we'll talk at you next week
[Music]